ادعاءات مقلقه من فرنسا حول التهاب اشرف
حكيمي بانه اغتصب احدى الفتيات
وسين ان تواصلت مع مكتب الادعاء للسؤال
حول القضيه مكتب الادعاء تفضل انه ما يعطي
كثير معلومات عن الموضوع حتى ما ياثر هذا
الشيء على مسار التحقيقات ويؤثر على
الوصول للحقيقه بالمقابل محامي اشرف حكيمي
اعطى تصريحات او محاميه اشرف حكيمي اعطت
تصريحات
واشارت فيها انه اللاعب ما ارتكب اي ذنب
وهو الان هادئ وتحت تصرف القضاء الفرنسي
وراح يكون متعاون جدا بالتحقيقات
التحقيقات الان جاريه حاولنا التواصل مع
اشرف حكيمي كاسيانا وحاولنا ايضا تواصل مع
باريس سان جيرمان ولكن كان في رفض للتعليق
حول هذا الموضوع حتى هذه اللحظه لحتى
تنعرف التفاصيل الاخرى بهاي القضيه خلينا
نشوف شو راح